[Music]
lies propaganda and welcome General
Michael Hayden former director of the
CIA and NSA dr. Vijay Raghavan
well-known scientist and also the
current state secretary and the
government of India and Catherine Meyer
the CEO of Wikimedia Foundation
Catherine you are the head of the
Wikimedia Foundation that runs Wikipedia
40 million articles 40 million art yes
that's right updated 300 times a minute
in 300 different languages yes I have
read somewhere that you have said that
it's fantastic something that wouldn't
work in theory actually works in
practice what do you mean by that well
we would say that it the only way it
would work is in practice what we mean
when we say that is the concept of
Wikipedia makes no sense how could you
get people from all over the world
speaking all these different languages
to agree on anything let alone very
controversial very sensitive subjects
whether its national borders or people's
religions or frankly even the people's
feelings about television shows and yet
it does and the reason that it does and
I think it's relevant to this
conversation today is because we're not
trying to solve the problems of
knowledge at scale we're actually
solving the problems of knowledge at
every single at the level of the
sentence and at the level of the
citation so we take a very big problem
and break it down to very small problems
to find some sort of consensus around
what our shared knowledge actually is
and do you manage to solve it
well more than 1 billion people visit
Wikipedia every single month so I think
we're adding some value to the world
certainly I'll keep looking to see you
know I think probably there's a lot of
users in the audience today thanks dr.
Badillo Raghavan scientist and
politician I guess as a politician you
are involved in areas close to
propaganda or at least trying to
convince people as a scientist maybe
you're focusing more I hope on facts
maybe even truth how do you balance that
that
or is there a balance to been to work
with first of all I'm a science
bureaucrat not a so my job my day job is
to present facts to our elected
representatives so that they can make
appropriate decisions and as a scientist
as we heard today there is evidence
which comes to bear on decision making
and everything we do as a scientist but
also evidence must come to bear on
policy now the trick is that and this is
very important is politicians are
elected every few years but hard
decisions need to be taken which have
consequences for implementation over a
much longer time period so how do you
actually communicate the possibilities
the range of decision making which
allows our elected representatives to
take decisions which are seen as being
valuable in the short term from a
political social economic point of view
but also have value in the long term in
terms of benefit to society and there is
a range of possibilities and therefore
communication with those who are elected
is very critical to convey that range of
possibilities yes we're gonna come back
to that of course General Michael Hayden
I saw that a few weeks ago you went out
with I think it was tweet only the
comments where you said that if this is
who we are becoming I have wasted 40
years of my life what did you mean by
that
yeah it was in response to a tweet that
the president put out there specifically
charging CNN International with creating
a misleading impression of America
sinned and responded with that's not our
job that's your job we report the news
but but I was offended but by the whole
context of the tweet which seemed to be
an assault on a free press on the First
Amendment and
truth at base and so I out of anger
tweeted nominated conditional you've got
to quote it quoted correctly if this is
who we are or if this is who we are
becoming
, I fear that I've wasted 40 years of my
life because you know in the Armed
Forces the United States you take the
oath of office to the Constitution
you're not not to the president not even
to the homeland it's to the Constitution
it's to the idea it's it's it's in its
own way a reminder that we're a creedal
nation based on creed rather than soil
and blood or even even shared history
and it seemed to me that the president
was just redefining that to which we
take the oath which is the idea of
America not a physical entity they often
say that that in in war truth is the
first casualty and I don't know if you
agree with me that there is some kind of
information war going on and maybe you
can say that there is a war going on
between the lies in the propaganda and
the facts and maybe truth do you agree
do you have any comments on that
yes I mean I think it's I find it very
interesting that you have organizations
like the International Cross and Red
Crescent talking about how do they think
about should it be within their mandate
to address the victims of information
war so I think we are in a place where
we're having a conversation that is very
different than we have had in the past I
mean set aside cyber war which is a very
real domain but we're talking about what
the the nature of information actually
looks like in this conflict and I've
spent a lot of time thinking about I
think we've talked a lot about the
problem set but we were just talking
what are the institutions what is the
obligation of institutions to actually
think about what the future looks like
if we actually want to pass through this
period with our integrity intact and do
you want to share what you if you can
come up with any conclusions or any one
of the aspects which has come out from
today's this morning's discussions and
what's happening now is there is a range
of views on what the ground reality is
about I mean whether there are lies
propaganda
the truth and how they're mixed but we
need to now move from there to ask two
questions one why is this happening and
two what are the solutions now it's
happening I don't know how it is
happening in society such as the United
States one hears about it but in many
parts of the world there is a danger of
alienation between those were the elites
who understand and are delving into
science for example or other
specializations and large numbers of
people who till recently were told what
is right or what is wrong about science
but who are not participating in the
understanding of science so unless we
bring in more and more people into
understanding the ways of science and
the ways of decision making and the ways
in which uncertainties are there yet
decision making can be made we are going
to broaden this gap and therefore
despite how our polarized discussions
are in America or elsewhere in the world
or in India or anywhere else
our job as scientists and science
administrators is to bring people into
the middle ground in terms of
discussions have civil debate about what
is possible and what is not given facts
and allowed a range of opinions to be
there using the same set of facts so
that's a challenge when you say we do
you mean we as the government we as
media we as citizens is a society I
think we as a society because I see a
worrying tendency to be certain in the
views in which we hold and certain about
what is right and what is wrong without
listening to other people who have
similar certain views now of course
there are certain there are areas where
you know one can't debate the facts the
facts stand as they are so I'm not
talking about those extremes I'm talking
about a penumbra where civil debate can
take place and we should actually get
people out of that penumbra into a zone
by one can discuss rather than push
pull away from that it's it's not yeah
Tara made a really interesting
distinction she said cyber information
and in the American sense I was kind of
president the creation I got assigned to
Texas in the mid-1990s to take over a
large command in the Air Force the
American Air Force was kind of cutting
edge when it came to the cyber thing and
there are lots of historical reasons but
most of what we were thinking or now has
now become American military doctrine I
mean well one thing we said was Lancie
aerospace cyber it's a domain it's a
place it's location
we're gonna go operate there which was
transformative simple now not them but
we had a debate back in the day in the
mid 1990s and it had all the intensity
of jesuits it of medieval University all
right
and it was were we in the cyber
dominance business or the information
dominance business and we looked at both
and the information dominance saying
cyber would be a subset but it would
include deception and public affairs and
public diplomacy it would go to
reactions everyone well that looks
really hard and number two was second it
was in number two you could not approach
it with in the American political
culture with without bumping immediately
into first and fourth amendment serious
concerns so we went over here we went
full speed ahead in the cyber lane
that's why we've now got a Cyber Command
the Russians went to curtain number two
under under you you can read it in
general grassy moss manuscript as to the
Russian threat of course any other
Russian or English it comes across good
it it talks about an opportunity for an
inherently weaker power in these other
domains to in an asymmetrical way
exercise contactless power contactless
influence and the Russians have matured
that one final comment which makes it
hard even harder for my own my country
to understand what happened
and to respond to it because we don't
own that lens that is not the lens with
which we are practiced at looking at
this thing what do you say that you did
a mistake back then or now we were it
was all we could do inside of American
values all right but we should have
studied the adversary more so as to
better understand what the adversary was
willing to do in terms of information
dominance very quickly Russian
separatists and Russian soldiers shot
down over an innocent Malaysian airliner
on course about three years ago and this
Russian information bubble information
dominance machine created so much
confusion that really good honest smart
people have simply decided wow I wonder
what really happened there and what
really happened there is obvious but
this Russian effort was was so
all-encompassing that it in essence took
truth off the table but one thing that
has changed I'm sorry to have a
conversation one thing that happened and
that has changed me in the time period
that you're describing is the vectors
themselves through which information
passes there has changed so
substantively when we look at the
consolidation of information
dissemination mechanisms and I am
talking the big corporate platforms that
are just responsible for most of the way
that many of us get our news and
information and that didn't exist it was
a far more diffuse information economy
in the past and so well the nature of
deception or propaganda is not new it's
state-sponsored misinformation is it's
been around for a very long time that
channels for distribution and the speed
of distribution has changed
significantly right and it put another
way it's less curated by these
institutions where it is generated but
it's created with very little
accountability well I think you ate it
well okay now that that what I would
agree but there there I think most
people get their news online through
social media through through a universe
in which they have self segregated into
like-minded folk and so if you're
talented that
you can push news forward make it appear
as if thousands if not millions of
people are saying so and goes into this
information bubble that the American
word is gerrymandered this is
gerrymandered as any state in the
American Union you only follow people
like you and they're there by this story
gets great power not out of its logic
but out of its numbers are the illusion
there yeah yes or the illusion of
numbers yes which I guess can lead us
into the question of transparency
because that of course becomes extremely
important when you either are in a
bubble or you should or trying to break
away and I guess it's fair to say that
that we have two very opposite positions
are you wiki pedia
I guess is the definition that is what
is all about WikiLeaks I want to be
clear right now we have CIA and as a
maybe not full transparency or and then
Indian government somewhere in between
maybe or my question is how important is
the question of transparency to really
reach call it fact or call it truth
what's the beginning so I think this is
a very critical point and while we're
talking about the ways social media can
disseminate you know news which as which
is not curated we must keep in mind for
large numbers of people all over the
world in South America in parts of Asia
India the impact of decision making is
very real and the impact of taking the
right decision can be very positive the
impact of taking a wrong decision can
have immediate consequences in a matter
of few years vaccinations maternal and
child health these are important
consequential decisions many people in
India for example still a great majority
of people get their news from newspapers
print media and they read a diverse set
of opinions in print media and they have
communities which interact with very
contradictory polls so many of the
stabilizing force
against random statements becoming truth
exist in many societies I think in
America for example they exist usually
in terms of constitutional checks and
balances as they're doing large
democracies and therefore I'm much less
pessimistic about the consequences of
runaway views causing drastic changes I
mean Michael in the comments so
obviously my business is best done in
secret but we see the trends of
transformation in in in the political
culture within which we reside and we
have to accommodate the political
culture if I say Edward Snowden everyone
understands what I mean and you get a is
a whole storyline in the American in the
American press about things done my old
agency was really slow off the mark
responding to that it was slow off the
mark because the most controversial
program when it involved American
privacy have been approved by not one
but two presidents was legislated by
Congress was overseen by two
congressional committees who were big
fans and checked by the by the court
every every sixty days till from our
point of view we called the Madisonian
trifecta all three branches of
government checked off that's how we get
legitimacy we thought we would be okay
and it turns out we weren't ok an awful
lot of Americans I'm not talking about
the wingnuts thought that was that no
longer constituted consent of the
governed that constituted consented the
governor's you may have told them you
didn't tell me and so my message to my
old tribe is we don't get to do this we
don't get the license to do this unless
we tell the public more about what it is
we do and that's hard because it's still
best done in secrecy Katherine I guess
your transparency as I was saying to
general Hayden yesterday we are actually
suing the NSA over these very programs
[Laughter]
oh yes and when I started the program so
we believe fundamentally that
transparency is important with it comes
to the integrity of information because
we believe that people should have the
right to know where that information
comes from the evidentiary chain of what
you're reading and where it came from
and your ability to scrutinize it and
read critically into that information is
so critical to an informed democracy so
I think that for us transparency is a
bedrock upon which we build everything
else and Trust does not
you cannot breed trust without that form
of integrity and accountability back to
the public and I would say that's true
not just for Wikipedia but for any
institution that's looking to serve the
public in this day and age so Katherine
Marc dr. Vijay Raghavan General Michael
alien thank you so much thank you
[Applause]